40,000 feet above the earth
aboard a luxury airship
that never touches the ground
for tax reasons,
it's "Down To Earth,"
with your host,
a regular normal person,
just like you,
Amy Schumer!
Oh!
We've got a great show
for you tonight!
But first, let's say "Hi"
to the Down to E Band,
Selena
and the Schume-tones!
♪♪
♪ She has a chef
for her dog ♪
♪ She bought
a convent in Prague ♪
♪ She owns three precogs ♪
♪ This girl is
just like you ♪
♪ J-j-j-just like you ♪♪
Look, at you,
Miss Rosetta Stone.
Look how good your English
has gotten, I love!
I was born in Texas.
So... now it's time
for our first segment,
I'm Just Like Us!
That's right, guys,
I get coffee and bagel,
just like me.
And that's my new miniature
dinosaur, Pom Pom,
wearing Narciso Rodriguez.
There are a lot
of misconceptions
about min-dins,
but believe you me,
they are the sweetest,
most loving pet
that you can pay
to have genetically
re-engineered.
Pom Pom is a rescue
from extinction
and Steven Spielby.
Okay, and then here's me
with Perez... Hilton.
So, look, I get a cup of joe,
no fancy drink for me.
I just say, coffee.
But, uh, uh,
you know what?
I have hard days
just like everyone else.
And here's what happened,
so the barista...
she got mad when
Pom Pom had to make shit.
So, I left,
and let's just say
I won't be going back.
♪♪
Today's topic is
using a hidden camera
to spy on your maid
who steals.
Let's go to the Relato-Cam
and see what mine is stealing.
There she goes again!
Stop stealing!
(speaking Spanish)
Do I have a maid? Yes.
Do I know her name? No.
But I'm just like you.
I still wash
my own legs.
I still do
my own masturbating.
Thank you.
Seleña,
am I saying that right?
Masturbating or my name?
(text alert pings)
Mmm, wow.
I didn't even know
I was up for that award.
(chuckles)
Here's a
life hack for you.
After I make a call
or take a vaggie,
I like to shred my phone
so it doesn't get hacked
by Internet robots who are
super jelly, like so.
(whirring)
Voilà!
Then have your
personal assistant
bring you a new phone.
Easy Peasy, beautiful.
Assistant!
♪♪
No, she does not
need walk-on music.
Ooh, thank you,
I love your blouse.
Alligators.
What is your name?
I'm your sister, Kim?
Ooh, "Sister Kim."
A nun, high-end.
Now we're gonna meet
our first guest.
Not a celebrity,
he's just a regular,
normal poor person
like Seleña.
My pilot, Jermone.
Jero-- Jerome.
Jerome.
♪♪
(Amy)
Careful, Jermone.
Here, have a seat.
You can take a knee
right there.
Fun, welcome
to the show.
No problem,
I was already here.
Just, uh...
steering the zeppelin.
I can relate,
interesting.
I'm just like you.
You're the boss lady,
Miss Schumer.
Miss Schumer is
my mother's pussy's name.
You can just call me
America's Golden Eagle.
Well, America's...
Golden Eagle.
Ew.
I just mainly
fly the zeppelin.
Mmm.
Refuel the zeppelin.
Do zeppelin repairs,
stuff like that.
(shutter clicks)
Actually, I should
probably get back
to the controls.
Nonsense,
you're my guest,
it's an honor.
For more information,
check out my lifestyle website.
Engorge.biz.
(loud whooshing)
Oh, my God,
what's going on?
Nobody's flying
the zeppelin, you idiot!
You have to go down
with the ship because
you're in the band,
and it's Titanic!
Or we could just
pull up the controls.
I mean, we're 40,000
feet up in the air.
No time!
We need to cut weight!
I can fix it!
Shut up!
(Jerome screams)
You need to be
my human parachute.
They have
real parachutes.
It's fine.
Shut up, Seleña!
Remember,
I'm just like you!
Well, I'm gonna
go fix this.
♪♪